here are the fastest ways to Checkmate  in chess you see this square that is the  weakest point at the beginning of any  chess game if you're gonna check me  quickly you have to exploit this Square  the fastest way that anyone can possibly  do this is like this  if white pushes these two Pawns in  either order fatally weakening that  Target Square we talked about all black  has to do is push the King Pawn to open  up the queen and bang Checkmate on the  side of the board in just two moves  now that Checkmate takes a bit of help  but this next one is actually much  easier to achieve  you bring out your King Pawn then your  bishop and queen gang up to attack that  weak Square we talked about if your  opponent doesn't defend you capture that  pawn with the queen and Bam Checkmate  once again in just four moves so keep an  eye out for these types of ideas defend  that weak square if you can and good  luck trying to get a fast Checkmate in  your next game